et je reviens en bon soir d'envoyer
n'importe qui je suis parce que dire à
stéphanie mais bon alors il faut environ
que trois dates qui raconte votre vie
1997 deuxième au tour de france
1998 est accusé de dopage et exclu du
tour ainsi que tous les coureurs de
l'équipe festina et 2000 après avoir nié
pendant 27 mois vous passer aux aveux
votre descente aux enfers votre mensonge
vaut aveu vous raconter tout ça dans un
livre qui est publié chez robert laffont
et qui s'appelle plus fort qu'avant vous
savez comment on fait richard virenque
attention
il voulait pas lâcher le guidon mais
il aimait 27 mois pourra jouer en même
temps bien alors donc ce livre est écrit
en collaboration avec jean paul vespini
qui est journaliste à la provence bon un
petit peu parlé de vous ma peut parler
de votre vie richard virenque
richard virenque vous êtes né au maroc
votre père travailler pour la société
kléber colombes vos parents avaient une
ville à casablanca dans le quartier
français et vous partiez passer vos
week-ends à 50 km de la plage de dahomey
il y avait trois tentes une tente
cuisine il tente chambre une tante
débarras et vous alliez pêcher des sols
avec le zodiac à marée basse
et puis votre famille il était obligé de
rentrer en france à cause d'un racisme
anti français vous dit que j'étais à
l'école accompagnés vivre avec les
volets fermés à la maison les gens jeter
des pierres sur les volets ils ont tué
votre chien ils ont tué notre berger
allemand en 178 les français ça a
commencé quand ce n'était pas bien vu et
ma mère avait envie de rentrer en france
on est rentré dans le var le maroc reste
pour vous une sorte de paradis perdu
d'une certaine façon oui c'est les
plages le soleil la chaleur est bon
plein de souvenirs de plage que j'ai pu
découvrir
et vous rentrez sans votre petit vélo
vert sur lequel vous aviez appris à
pédaler parce que ceux des lots y avait
pas de place pour lui dans les valises
d'un des fils de téléphone ce
qu'on croit être fort et puis lorsque
voilà et alors heureusement toujours
dans la vie vers l'âge de 12 13 ans
votre frère lionel vous fait découvrir
le cyclisme
et vous rentrez dans un vélo club vous
commencez à faire vos débuts de
cyclistes début amateurs donc on
commence à 14 ans et après on enchaîne
toutes les catégories et à partir de 17
ans j'ai commencé à avoir des capacités
pour penser à aller un peu plus loin
d'enlever ou mais ça marche très bien
parce que dès l'âge de 18 ans il ya un
tour régional et vous remporté cinq
étapes sur six donc très rapidement vous
révéler être un très bon cycliste
ce succès c'est pour vous faire
pardonner vos échecs scolaires oui c'est
parce que je me suis un moment je me
suis un peu réfugier dans le vélo parce
que je sentais que c'était peut-être là
où j'avais un avenir et à l'école je me
sentais vraiment pas bien j'étais plus
là pour pour animer la classe et pour
être un peu le pitre que pour faire
j'irai apprendre à travailler je me
sentais mieux à l'extérieur qu'à
l'intérieur ouais puis vous devancé
l'appel pour le service militaire et
vous allez au bataillon de joinville
donc des jeunes s'adonnent à un niveau
bien entendu et puis si le début de
votre carrière en 92 à 22 ans c'est
votre premier tour de france et vous
êtes maillot jaune pour la deuxième
étape est là toute la nuit vous posez le
maillot sur une sur une chaise et toute
la nuit vous regardez le maillot oui bah
insérer une toute la nuit répondre
changer de couleur non mais c'est de
rentrer dans le tour de france en étant
néo professionnel et d'arrivée de gagner
le maillot jaune maillot le plus
convoité de prendre le maillot aussi à
pois le maillot vert si j'avais rafler
tous les maillots mais j'ai rentré dans
une intrigue en matière du tour par la
grande porte et ensuite eh ben ça a été
tirée c'est monté crescendo et j'ai
toujours aimé le tour de france vous
dites mon premier tour de france j'avais
accompli à l'eau claire j'ai fini 25e
oui mais bon c c'est prometteur quand on
est jeune on aimerait véronique en
prenant deux trois trucs qu'on veut
finir premier en même temps oui
peut-être au 6 mai
j'avais des cas une carrière qui s'ouvre
est devant moi alors cinor de votre
troisième tour de france que vous êtes
confrontés au dopage pour la première
fois donc vous rentrez dans l'équipe
festina la fameuse équipe de bruno
roussel et de villiers veux tu et puis
du fameux bernard cents le docteur
mabuse alors là vous raconter dans votre
bouquin comment ça se passe d'ailleurs
vous dites ça se déroule comme une
visite médicale normal oui quoi à
l'époque il y avait les règles étaient
simples
il y avait des contrôles qui était
instaurée et il fallait pas dépasser
giresse à rester aux contrôles urinaires
et donc il y avait beaucoup de substance
qui n'était pas retrouvée donc on
n'était pas dans les prises de sang donc
à l'époque j'avais la vie était belle
pour les contrôles donc
quand l affaire festina éclaté va
ça a changé la donne et est-ce que vous
avez essayé le pot belge oui
qu'est-ce que c'est le pot belge michel
c'est un mélange un mélange de cocktail
qui cloue vont ya tout dedans un maillet
une sensation de dodo faurie et cheveux
qui poussent sans la tête
ça peut marcher
en tous les cas à richard virenque vous
êtes le seul français à avoir revêtu
cinq fois le maillot à pois rouges du
meilleur grimpeur ça fait rêver un
meilleur grimpeur
et puis le 8 juillet 98 ville et veuthey
arrêté à la frontière franco-belge donc
avec sa voiture bourrée de dope on voit
pleurer devant les caméras de france 2
vous partez en hélico avec votre frère
vous n'êtes ni 30 heures en garde à vue
et vous dites dans votre livre le roi de
la montagne se retrouve au fond du trou
c'est un truc que j'aime à dire ils vous
emmènent fait une fouille rectale quoi
alors richard les policiers vous disent
les autres ont avoué pourquoi tu
n'avoues pas vous refuser parce que je
savais que le moment j'allais parler
jallet moto suspendre donc
celui qui parlait il était suspendu et
matic mans comme je l'avais jamais subi
de contrôle positif
ouais donc et pas de preuves en même
temps non alors là le public commence à
réaliser que donc t-il armstrong mais
finalement tous les cyclistes se sont
toujours dopés que robert chapatte le
savait et qui nous avait rien dit
voilà les médias vous tombe dessus
les guignols évidemment un à l'insu de
mon plein gré c'est quand même devenir
un classique maintenant comment à
l'époque vous regardé les guignols non
je suis tombé sur quelques j'irai série
où quelques clips des guignols il y en a
quelques-uns qui m'ont qui m'ont choqué
qu'ils m'ont fait mal ouais qui ont fait
mal à mes proches et il y en a
quelques-uns qui m'ont fait rire aussi
et là il ya un truc et s est
incompréhensible c'est qu'en 99 malgré
tout vous réintégrer le tour pour vice
de forme alors le blanc vient vous
serrer la main mais pas devant les
caméras enfin tout le monde est un petit
peu gêné vous prenez le départ avec un
garde du corps à côté de vous enfin ces
situations un petit peu étrange et en
2000 vous avouez vous dites oui c'est
vrai j'ai pris des produits dopants
j'avais pas le choix alors le président
du tribunal vous dis mais finalement
votre maillot à pois vous l'avez arraché
de le perron et vous répondez cette
phrase définitif
si vous croyez qu'il suffit de se mettre
des piqûres dans le cul pour avancer il
a été nommé comme je lui dise ah ouais
suspendu neuf mois donc et au coi pour
le
camp des ont dépassé le seuil de 50 cl
avec un jour de de vacances et moi comme
j'ai avoué donc c'est comme un cas
positif donc on m'a suspendu mais les
coureurs qui avaient été suspendues à
l'époque avant moi pour les mêmes faits
donc les mes copains festina qui avait
avoué il avait une suspension trois mois
à l'hiver sans compétition et trois mois
en saison en compétition est moins là
suspens quand on a mis la suspension je
me suis dit bon je vais prendre un peu
plus parce que j'ai j'ai un peu attendu
avant de parler et là ils m'ont mis neuf
mois ferme donc aujourd'hui c'est j'ai
été le courant le plus suspendu
maintenant vous êtes clean oui vous
roulez à l'eau claire ouest a fait vous
avez plus jamais gagné si maintenant des
abonnements ou les autres ce dossier
vous dopez pas vous n'avez pas gagné
j'ai gagné une des plus belles courses
paris tours en 2001 ouais je sais
vas-y rien pris ce jour-là un an
maintenant on peut faire du vélo sans se
défoncer et oui en gagnant une coupe du
monde la plus plate devant les grands
sprinteurs j'ai fait 240 kilomètres
d'échappée ouais le vent de face avec
jacky durand et j'ai tenu tête au
peloton et je sais c'est pour ça que
l'équipe dôme où vous à vous a gardé les
richard virenque
si vous étiez sûr de gagner le tour de
france en vous dopants mais sans être
pris est ce que vous le feriez
saisir gagner le tour de france on ne
doit penser après oui
merci richard miron alain richard vous
avez vidéo vous avez eu débat on va
faire une interview à penda
l'ennemi
non ce que tu fais c'est pitoyable non
c'est un mouvement la lutte est en
marche terry surveille internet tu vas
avoir des surprises ouais donc sur
internet social qu'est les hardis
sonnette maintenant richard virenque
que préférez vous en vous
la gentillesse là un bon thé oui
qu'est-ce que vous ne supportez pas en
vous
mais j'ai remarqué trop positives comme
gaza
je sors d'une mauvaise vanne ces
mauvaises bases qu'est ce que vous
préférez dans le cyclisme
je mets pilule pour les bonnes vannes
attend
cela
je perdais superman maintenant je vous
déchirez tout cela
arrive qu'est ce que vous préférez dans
le cyclisme richard d'être de monter des
cols et d'être encouragés pendant la
nuit à tous les virages
wayne rooney qu'est-ce que vous haïssez
dans le cyclisme
courir sous la pluie ouais le plus grand
moment de votre vie c'était quand la
naissance de mes enfants et le pire
moment le pire moment c'est
'cependant cela faire retirer le tout ce
que ça a pu causer au niveau familial
ce qui vous fait le plus marrer dans la
vie c'est quoi brosser les
tout ce qui est vidéo gag caméras
cachées ainsi nous fallait d'affilée ou
fait mal oui il est pas mauvais merci
bien
car si bordeaux
et chats qu'est ce qui vous fait le plus
chier dans la vie du chien dans la vie c
la maladie la pauvreté les gens qui sont
vraiment dans la misère ouais
votre plus gros coup de fric c'est quoi
c'est après le tour 97 donc si le
contrat que j'ai signé avec festina en
98 ouais
la plus grosse perte six mois après
votre plus belle histoire d'amour ben
celle que j'ai en ce moment avec ma
femme ça dure toujours resté fanny ça
durera cette histoire vous l'avez
rencontré commencer la haine raciale
oui
j'ai pris bonne note j'ai pris un
laxatif je crois bien
et va plus moche histoire d'amour
j'en ai pas eu arrêt non
ce que vous avez des plus sexy en vous
les fesses je crois ça leur plaît aux
filles les garçons qui ont déjà tous
avaient volé les fesses si vous avez de
moins sexy en vous richard les marques
de bronze 1 vous avez marre du marcel
non non non deux
dumas oui ah oui ah oui du cuissard
l'ont donc à ses pattes et rich préférez
quoi dans le sexe
[Musique]
l'acte l'acte charnel non mais dans
l'acte charnel à
sa femme prend la pilule c'est
maintenant le plaisir est ce qui vous
dégoûte dans le sexe
que ça jure que ça dure jamais assez
longtemps ah oui vous êtes à
l'éjaculation précoce richards n'ont
pourtant non mais mais malgré tout
malgré tout
josé mari que ça dure encore plus j'ai
les capacités d'endurance mais toujours
on aimerait aller plus loin je sais qui
est des produits pour ça
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous je m'étais 1
pouces bleus